hello there I'm gap I'm done we're the
slow mo guys Dan the other day we had a
conversation didn't we yeah and I was
like how can we get two paintballs to
collide midair and film it in slow
motion my first thought was we're just
gonna stand opposite each other and just
let rip and then hopefully would never
happen it would not curacy the timing it
would never happen the pain
the pay's well fear you'd be scared like
this I've had bad luck with people's
yeah oh that looks like good shut to
mouth Gavin you look like a mess my face
off it looks like you have a second
mouth it's not pleasant it's not nice so
instead I've made this contraption with
the vice grips and string yeah I mean it
is a complex thing for us yeah but in
the grand scheme of Internet videos it's
very basic I mean there could be like an
electronic button to just do it instead
I've just bought two guns and sort of
tried to rig them up to the shooting
each other okay so we'll see if we can
collide two paintballs somewhere around
here I'm going to preset the focus and
the framing but you know probably around
will film it at 28,000 500 frames a
second on the V 25:11 and if we're
feeling a little bit cheeky will boost
that framerate up
juicy we can get juicy juicy so
somewhere around here yeah yeah just
just like all right so you're just dying
it
I mean it's so miniscule but I'm gonna
try and I yeah it's just kind of
difficult because sometimes when you
clamp it back up it just goes back where
it wants a little bit a gift yeah it's
better given the plastic of the gun we
had if we had like a cylindrical rod we
could just shove it down both barrels
it's true we don't know yeah if we were
more prepared it'd be easier so let's
see how that goes you ready yeah
yep how's it yep what's up I think they
just bought
they hit yeah they did he may just
glanced each other slightly well the
chances of that come on you ready right
yeah think that the green one just
annihilated one survived it's just like
when when you get hit and paintball it
doesn't explode it's there like tape or
something on that paper no it's like
half of its got the branding pattern I
think on it a little bit the pattern
sort of swung off and spun away oh yeah
pretty speed it into the distance yeah
my first adjustment was too much yeah
any meant that they just dinked so I've
readjusted that time and only one of
them exploded and they weren't quite
bang on so this time I've adjusted again
it's a little bit and hopefully we'll
get that exact meaty little yeah little
and that's kneecap yeah yep so I
actually saw the exact second that they
they hit each other you know neat you
know when you close your eyes and you
like freeze frame with you I captured
that perfect I win like book and I just
sort of explode can you send that video
yeah yeah hang on since in the JPEG
alright okay I got ya drop turned on
yeah got it
yeah man this cameras lab alright
playing back nailed it
perfect that's amazing so it looks like
they hit on the back like one
yeah just slightly look at the open
house like like a fruit it's like a
kumquat yeah here it's like juicy and
then it turns into like a spiderweb it
always looks like a nervous system
though back neurons
yeah or like a pillories or something
yeah well how much that actually happens
in like real paintball matches it must
happen quite a bit yeah
is that square on enough for joint
anymore adjustments that's pretty good
so satisfying getting the first time
yeah I thought these are made of rubber
but they're actually made of like
plastic there's quite thick you can see
the difference in there in the
paintballs this one split along the
actual that like the steel hole yeah the
two different kinds of plastic that's
seal the paint in and this one is just
sort of burst all over the place I think
these are the more expensive ones and
these are like the cheaper ones hmm so
right I guess yeah we've run I guess so
they're sort of flopping out the gun
instead of firing out need to leave more
beans more beans how do you remove it
without it spread everywhere I don't
know think you can sweaty Anzhi Jesus
yeah let's soaked me sometimes it's hard
to tell when it actually happens yeah I
still wonder how many wasn't it yeah
that's so satisfying
it's amazing that even though one comes
out way before the other they still meet
perfectly in focus
that's so weird is it just that I'm
always pulling one slightly letting say
I think it's just there's a slight delay
so I mean even if you do that in slow
mode there's always gonna be one that
goes before the other what an operation
this is all right yeah yeah yeah
excellent shooting thank you very much
sir excellent shooting for you too
oh thank you
[Music]
[Music]
it's so weird because there's probably
milliseconds in the difference but I'm
pulling them there but in slow-mo just
looks like an age like it's halfway to
the gun before these three minutes less
count so that one's at the end of the
barrel
well it's three fifty two thirty three
seconds
point 104 two three one okay so what's
the first number that's a tenth of a
second what's the third number thousand
so I'm 12 thousandths of a second out
should be ashamed of yourself call
myself a slo-mo guy made a mess of the
other board there you know and the fence
over here the thing is I figured that
this fence was further away so the
pattern would be a bit more spread how
long do you think it would take me to
paint the whole fence for the paintball
there well week a week yeah
like solid it's going bang bang bang
bang bang wouldn't be very
cost-effective because during all the
paintballs and the co2 uni it'd be a lot
okay I don't know how much that would
cost it's not very drippy is it and look
it's very powdery so weird
Oh every time I do a paintball video
without you doing that didn't get me
though really no just me
that's so fortunate I've meant to have
the clean lab coat sorry it does come
off quite does it yeah tell you what the
blue man head didn't come off I didn't
it didn't dry either I think you need
about a month later I should get you
like you should hmm I mean I need one
but today it's just not in the budget
quite like those shots very satisfying
to watch just the way the paint spreads
in sort of random patterns different
every time I can just watch them collide
all day well sometimes I couldn't
actually tell if they've hit unless it
was the only way I could tell is if
there was no noise on the fence either
side yeah because there would be nothing
left
sometimes they would hit but depending
on the timing they'd hit sort of over
here and clip or over here but they
would nail each other here yeah but it
was interesting because the
it is all jostle II and that the
pressure from pulling the triggers the
barrels as you were pulling them we're
doing that so I'm amazed that they ever
hit each other like I think they just
come out so fast that by the time the
barrels react and move around the
paintballs already come out like when
you saw with the the close-up shot of
the paintball gun yeah it came out and
then it went like yeah this time we
didn't shoot each other but we still
made a videos with paintball guns yeah
that's good guy we're evolving we don't
always have to hurt each other I know
well though you did say can I shoot you
in the face with that I said no well
hopefully you enjoyed that video feel
free to follow us on Twitter oh I got
myself a bad fire feel free to subscribe
to the slow mo guys we do slow mo all
the time and also we have a second
channel full of behind the scenes and
extra guff good flying yeah I'm getting
good at this now we'll see you in the
next video thanks for watching gotta
wipe down all the equipment Oh on the
laptop sorry let's go wash off that go
on my face yeah